klicks um science-fiction heute mit dem
wohl bekanntesten
wissenschaftsjournalisten der welt nil
dem raps kreisen als gast donald trump
hält nicht viel von wissenschaft und das
ist tragisch er stellt den klimawandel
infrage und will generell die mittel für
forschung einschränken von wegen make
america gratis
jetzt stehen die amerikanischen
wissenschaftler auf zum 1
im vorfeld hat mein kollege douglas
teyssen die laut ihnen wichtigste
botschaft seines lebens verbreitet von
mir geht einen riesen lagern ihn und die
produktionsfirma red glas pictures die
mich gebeten haben ihn hier bei kings of
science fiction mit diesem video
exklusiv in der deutschen übersetzung zu
präsentieren also nie doris theisen
herzlich willkommen
karl demmer wie es amerika aus einem
rückständigen land zu einer der größten
nationen geworden die die welt je
gesehen hat wir haben pionierarbeit in
der industrie geleistet und das alles
erfordert sie die größten innovationen
in wissenschaft und technik auf der welt
wissenschaft ist ein fundamentaler teil
des landes das aber in diesem im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wenn
entscheidung auf der grundlage von
wissenschaft getroffen werden müssen
scheint es mir dass die menschen die
fähigkeit verloren haben zu beurteilen
was wahr ist und was nicht wahr ist was
ist nachgewiesen was ist nicht
nachgewiesen was kannst du glauben was
kannst du nicht glauben und wenn dann
leute an die macht kommen die nicht viel
von wissenschaft verstehen die sie
ablehnen dann ist das ein rezept für den
vollständigen abbau unserer informierten
demokratie
lassen sie uns fordern dass pädagogen in
amerika die evolution nicht als tatsache
sondern als theorie lehrern eine
zunehmende anzahl von eltern steigt
skepsis gegenüber impfungen
die wähler haben für ein verbot von gvo
gestimmt kritiker nennen klima weile
unbewiesene wissenschaft concertos nicht
das land in dem ich aufgewachsen bin
nicht dass wir keine probleme hatten
ich bin alt genug um mich an die 60er
und 70er jahre erinnern
wir hatten einen heißen kultur einen
kalten kriegs und eine
bürgerrechtsbewegung es war eine menge
los
aber ich erinnere mich nicht an
irgendeine zeit wo die wissenschaft
veröffentlicht wurde
[Musik]
und das tolle an wissenschaft ist dass
es eine ständige suche nach der wahrheit
sie haben einen prothese sie testen sie
ich bekomme ein ergebnis ein konkurrent
von mir double check lässt weil er denkt
dass ich falsch liegen könnte er führt
ein noch besseres experiment als ich
durch und findet heraus
hey dieses experiment passt oh mein gott
wir sind hier auf etwas gestoßen
eine neue erkenntnis verbreitet sich in
der welt münchen
diese vorgehensweise funktioniert besser
als alles andere was sich die menschheit
bisher ausgedacht hat das ist
wissenschaft sie ist nicht zu spielen da
ich kann nicht sagen dass ich nicht
glaube dass er gleich ma c quadrat
stimmt diese option gibt es nicht wenn
es eine etablierte wissenschaftliche
wahrheit ist sie war ob man daran glaubt
oder nicht
und je früher du das verstehst desto
schneller können wir mit den politischen
gesprächen über die probleme denen wir
gegenüberstehen beginnt
zur wunsch nun früher wir verstanden
hast dass der klimawandel von menschen
gemacht ist desto früher kannst du
politische gespräche darüber beginnen
wie man die probleme lösen kann
sie können sagen da sind die co2
emissionsrechte machen wir das setzen
wir einen zoll drauf fördern wir
subventionieren leer
darauf brauchen die politische antworten
durch ruß und jede minute in der jemand
das ablehnt verzögert er die politische
lösung die schon vor jahren hätte
gefunden werden müssen
gegenüber uns wählern und bürgern soll
die wissenschaft immer wieder fragen
aufwerfen und lohnt es sich da nicht zu
sagen okay lass mich wenigstens das
prinzip der wissenschaft grundsätzlich
verstehen damit ich über diese fragen
nachdenken und intelligent auf sie
reagieren kann
recognizr erkennt was wissenschaft ist
und erlaubt ihr das zu sein was sie kann
im dienste der zivilisation
es liegt in unseren händen
vielen dank niedriger streisand da
bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen wenn er
dran bleiben wollen wenn diese
diskussion weitergeht las ein abo da und
gebt mir noch einen auf die glocke also
bis dann bleib dran
jo